[Music]
the discovery of an alien monolith on
Planet rh17 29 has scientists across the
world racing to unlock its mysteries
your engineering team has developed an
elegant probe to study it the probe is a
collection of 27 cubed modules capable
of running all the scientific tests
necessary to analyze the monolith the
modules can self-assemble into a large
three by three by three cube with each
individual module placed anywhere in the
cube and at any orientation it can also
break itself apart and reassemble into
any other orientation now comes your job
the probe will need a special protective
coating for each of the extreme
environments it passes through the red
coating will seal it against the cold of
deep space the purple coating will
protect it from the intense heat as it
enters the atmosphere of rh17 29 and the
green coating will shield it from the
alien planets electric storms you can
apply the coatings to each of the faces
of all 27 of the cubic modules in any
way you like but each face can only take
a single color coating you need to
figure out how you can apply the colors
so the cubes can reassemble themselves
to show only red then purple then green
how can you apply the colored coatings
to the 27 cubes so the probe will be
able to make the trip
you
you can start by painting the outside of
the complete cube red since you'll need
that regardless then you can break it
into 27 pieces and look at what you have
there are eight corner cubes which each
have three red faces twelve edge cubes
which have two red faces six face cubes
which have one red face and a single
center cube which has no red faces
you've painted a total of 54 faces red
at this point so you'll need the same
number of faces for the green and purple
cubes too when you're done you'll have
painted 54 faces red 54 faces green and
fifty four faces purple that's 162 faces
which is precisely how many the cubes
have in total so there's no margin for
waste if there's any way to do this
it'll probably be highly symmetrical
maybe you can use that to help you you
look at the center cube you'd better
paint it half green and half purple so
you can use it as a corner for each of
those cubes and not waste a single face
there will need to be Center cubes with
no green and no purple too so you take
two corner cubes from the red cube and
paint the three blank faces of one
purple and the three blank faces of the
other green now you've got the six face
cubes that each have one face painted
red that leaves five empty faces on each
you can split them in half in the first
group you paint three faces green and
two faces purple in the second group
paint three faces purple and two green
counting on symmetry you replicate these
piles again with the colors rearranged
that gives you six with one green face
six with one red face and six with one
purple face counting up what you've
completely painted you see eight corner
cubes in each color six edge cubes in
each color six face cubes in each color
and one center cube that means you just
need six more edge cubes in green and
purple and there are exactly six cubes
left each with four empty faces you
paint two faces of each green and two
faces of each purple and now you have a
cube that's perfectly painted to make an
incredible trip
it rearranges itself to be read in deep
space purple as it enters rh17 two 9s
atmosphere and green when it flies
through the electric storms as it
reaches the monolith you realize you've
achieved something humans have dreamt of
for eons alien contact that's one method
to paint the cubes but it's not the only
one today's bonus riddle is this how
many distinct ways are there to paint
the cubes in other words some of the 27
smaller cubes will be different from
method to method but they can still be
assembled into red purple and green
three by three by three cubes every time
if you're not sure how to get started
head on over to brilliant by using the
link in the description below
our partners at brilliant have created
an excellent exploration that will guide
you towards the solution without just
giving away the answer you'll learn how
to break the problem into its component
pieces think clearly through each part
and build it back up to a conclusion and
while you're there consider signing up
for a premium account the first eight
hundred thirty three of you to do so
will get 20% off the annual subscription